hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comet today we are in game
8 of the match of the century 1972 World
Chess Championship between Bobby Fischer
and buddy Spassky Bobby Fischer lost the
first two games of this series second
game actually forfeited but since these
have been on series won three of the
last five the other two they did tie so
Bobby Fischer is up one game in the
series coming here to game eights Bobby
Fischer's playing the white pieces so
we're going to get started Bobby Fischer
starts out with pawn to c4 now he played
C for just a few games ago which is
pretty uncommon for Bobby Fischer he's
pretty much well known for pawn to e4
and usually doesn't play pawn to c4 ever
at all now he did transpose into the
Queens gambit declined line earlier but
this particular game he decides to go
and just go full-blown English opening
we see pawn c4 pawn c5 Knight c3 knight
c6 we start getting into the English
symmetrical meaning that buddy Spassky
is just going to mirror the moves from
Bobby Fischer you don't see this as much
and high-level play anymore I really
only see it when I play my friends and
the goal is to see how long we can
mirror our opponent's moves until
someone does something really really
really bad and the goal for white
specifically is try to find out which
moves you can try to make your opponent
match and then that will actually
destroy the game for them if you haven't
played it before it's actually pretty
fun we get through a few more moves
after pawn to g3 bond g6 be incredible
on the kingside Castle castle pawn to d4
and then buddy Spassky on the seventh
move decides okay I've had enough I
don't want to marry you moves anymore
and decides to go ahead and take here on
d4 we start to see some exchanges on
board Bobby Fischer takes knight on d4
Spassky responds Knight takes on d4
Queen takes on d4 pawn to d6 and then
Bishop g5 and Bobby Fischer completes
his development now Bishop to e6 just
getting more pieces involved into the
action after the Queen moves buddy
Spassky will also complete development
Bobby Fischer brings his queen over to
f4 very interesting move
bring your queen over here he had some
other options bishop just takes on b7
seems logical rook b8 bishop back here
f3
we could see pawn age 6 if you wanted to
he's going to need to get that back
material if you wanted to after the
bishop moves could come back down here
to be 2 unless bishop comes back he
really wanted to don't know if you would
actually do that so you can just take
right away rook takes on b2 Queen takes
here on a7 you could have the bishop
down take on c4 so lots of different
options but instead Bobby Fischer goes
for a little bit unorthodox move with
Queen to f4 a queen down here a 5
putting little pressure on the night
look over here C 1 so can push a little
forward connect these pawns and still
have protection on this night right here
rook b8 pawn here to b3 as we talked
about and then broke over here to c8 so
both sides just getting their piece a
little bit more involved into the action
rook over here and see a controlling the
semi open file always a good thing to do
then the Queen comes back here to d2
allowing for a discovered attack on the
Queen here later on into the game so
anytime you have your Queens looking
each other up with a piece in the middle
they always have to keep an eye on that
we do see pawn to a6 and then Bishop to
e3 and Bishop to e3 is an interesting
move because it pretty much tells but
he's fast exactly what Bobby Fischer's
trying to do he's trying to bring his
bishop and he's trying to bring in here
to a7 because if this rook has to move
then all of a sudden that this pawn is
going to be vulnerable with this Bishop
here on at g2 now with that said buddy
Spassky looked at this and said I'm
gonna play pawn to b5 it's just a little
bit weird because it doesn't really stop
the bishop coming here to a7 and then
only that but yes the pawn won't fall
now but if the rook moves to a 8 it's
now vulnerable to the bishop from g2 so
Bobby Fischer immediately plays Bishop
to a7 attacking the rook if we come back
here and say well what other options to
be had
few options most logically we just say
Bishop to b6 this does stop it right
away can't come here take the the rooks
going to take it if you wanted to could
evens have rook to e8 this does open up
the door if the bishop were to come here
to a7 for the rook to move could come to
see it if you want to
dat has some options there but all in
all decided to go ahead and play what I
would say is a fairly bad move unless he
has some competition afterwards with
pawn to b5 and then after Bobby Fischer
plays Bishop to a7 we see the pawn take
on c4 ok that's completely ok with Bobby
Fischer he's going to go ahead and take
the rook here on b8 and after the rook
takes pawn takes after the Bishop takes
then the rook over here to a d1 so all
in all Bobby Fischer up a pawn in this
position right here but he's adding a
lot of pressure on the board he still
has that discovered attack if he ever
plays Knight to d5 that's going to be
pretty deadly has to definitely watch
out for that he's controlling to serve
the board with these rooks very very
nicely he has the fully open file C file
with his rook and the semi open file in
the circuit board which is going to be
very very powerful with his Queen and
his rook here on d1 also but he's
fatzkee has to be aware of this
LightSquared bishop controlling this
long diagonal Bobby Fischer very well
known for controlling the light agonal
from both sides of the board sometimes
he's bring his vision over here to a2
and kind of control this but on the
other side when he think hitters to the
King side definitely well known for kind
of sneaky attacks controlling this long
center diagonal now from here but he's
fast key goes a pretty interesting route
he had some options here a Bishop e6
makes a lot of sense does not want to
get blown out by Knight to d5 a nice
little protection from that but instead
decides to play Knight to d7 and I'm
just not sure that he saw or maybe he
did just didn't care
but the Knight to d5 discovered attack
on the Queen really has to deal with
that he would like to just take his
Bishop here but after the Queen takes
then all of a sudden the rook is still
dominating the center file so if we
start seeing change on board
there's only nothing else that buddy
Spassky can do besides take this Queen
right here but Knight takes on e7 that's
going to be the extra pawn he's going to
get in this position check the the king
is forced to move so a little in-between
move before the Queen falls after King
to f8 we see rook on D to capture after
the King takes then the rook comes up
here to c4 and bobby fischer's now up to
pawns in material 8 I'm going to give
two pawns to your opponent you really
need to come out with a really strong
attack some sort of big combination that
your opponent's not really gonna be able
to deal with or maybe get into the in
game with just better pieces on board
but each basky does not have that you
can even see his pieces are somewhat
passive behind his King on e7 yeah you
can get that involved into the action
but he doesn't really have any strong
attacks he has an isolated pawn here on
the D file the pawn structure for Bobby
Fischer is probably even a little bit
stronger and two rooks getting into the
in game is going to be very very
difficult for buddy Spassky to deal with
Spassky decides to start with a route
down here to be one Czech Bishop down
here f1 protection Knight to c5 outpost
move King to g2 pawn on a5 starting to
push on the King side or queen side
trying to do something on board pawn to
e4 I think it's somewhat funny that
Bobby Fischer waits till the 26 move to
actually play pawn to e4 had a few
options to play it earlier on game even
if it was just pawn to e3 but he wanted
to wait since he always starts out with
pawn to e4 waiting this late in the game
I think is just funny
Bishop down here to a1 I think this is a
completely wasted by buddy's faster you
want your bishop to control a lot of the
board
he was already controlling this long
diagonal right here bringing it from g7
out here to 81 not really cutting off
any squares definitely not controlling
any more of the board I don't know that
Bobby Fischer was really looking to do
anything that this stops on board so
it's kind of weird
my vision is okay I'll just kind of let
you do your thing over here pawn to f4
pushing on the kingside pun f6 rook over
here e to just getting it behind the
pawns who can push forward with more
protection
King e6 rook to a situ just adding more
pressure on some of these critical
squares also anytime you can just get
your rooks connected it's going to be a
good thing now he may not want to take
right away he doesn't want to give up
material Demmel not going to exchange a
rook for a knight's but later on he
could have a nice little combo bishop
here to be - just looks like but as
fatzke has no idea how or where he's
going to be moving his pieces Bishop e2
h5 rook here to d2 and then after Bishop
to a3 we see pawn to f5 and this is a
really nice deflection he's actually
deflecting against h5 this is a very
critical square on board Bobby Fischer
yes he is up in material but really
needs to find the endgame but he Spassky
is doing a good job blocking off a lot
of the ways that Bobby Fischer is going
to get past enemy lines here with the
night here
the outpost with the King protection
right here the way for victory is a very
very long endgame or Bobby Fischer can
blow up the King side the board pushes
pawns pass promote one of these to a
queen and win the game very easily
that's exactly a pawn to f5 does because
it takes away the protection that the
square here on h5 has if the palm pushes
forward great the bishop can just take
here on h5 if we see here pawn takes
here on f5 great this is exactly what
Bobby Fischer wants he can later on just
take bishop here on h5 and then start to
push his pawns can't really protect it
much more especially when you have two
rips you can easily just swing your rook
over here later on if you had to get
your other work involved into the game
there's just no way for buddies baskets
really defend this this is I had to play
a King to e5 it's just a blowout if he
decides to go and take this King takes
here on f5 and then we see rook takes
the nights after the pawn takes then we
have a for Bishop to d3 and after the
King moves the bishop comes back here b1
and this is just complete annihilation
so decides to draw it out a little bit
further and instead of taking he plays
King down to e5 rook to d4 just doubling
up with his rooks getting ready to take
material right here
after the king takes rook up here to d5
and then we see Rick up to d6 check a
wall taking material then after King to
e7 we have a rook to c6 and buddy
Spassky decides to go ahead and resign
there's no way for him to really stop
the attack that Bobby Fischer has one of
the next few moves Bishop to h5 starting
to push forward if he wants to the
combination of the two rooks and the
bishop is just going to be too much so
buddy Spassky decides to go ahead and
resign so Bobby Fischer just been on its
hair he loses Game one he forfeits Game
two because he's kind of a crybaby and
then after that he's won four of the
last six and but he's fast key seems to
have no answer for Bobby Fischer so all
in all I think he played a pretty poor
game that is Spassky were talking about
for game eight the English symmetrical I
don't think is a strong suit he's never
going to be the aggressor never going to
be putting Bobby Fischer in any tough
lines you're just copying your
opponent's move waiting for them to do
something so Bobby Fischer doesn't play
much c4 but so far in this tournament he
has done extremely well but Bobby
Fischer being one of the best players of
all time especially during his
generation being one of the best way
beyond some of his other competitors but
he's basking included in that argument
but all Bobby Fischer congratulations to
him game eight he does take a two-game
advantage going into game nine so
hopefully you guys enjoyed and I'll see
you in game nine thanks for watching